well yumna say joins us now on the phone
from Gaza City and yumna the casualties
rise and often Palestinian casualties
are seen just as numbers I talk us
through what happened to some of the
people who were hit in the strikes on
hospitals and also a residential
building five stories that we were
talking to hany earlier on and said we
don't we weren't sure at that point what
happened to the people inside
well shy as you see and as the whole
world sees many of the casualties or
most of the casualties in the Israeli
air strikes are for children mainly
children now people who go to take
refuge in hospitals like Hospital a
shifa hospital and other hospitals
they're mainly families uh children
women and elderly that are afraid for
their families lives and they take them
to the hospital as the best and the
safest place for Refuge but then they
are targeted there all homes that are
being targeted now and I'm not talking
about residential Towers but homes they
are being
targeted while their residents are
inside them and most of those residents
are mainly children this is what we have
been seeing over and over and over all
the targeting that have happened today
in Khan unun and in Raa in Gaza City
they were all for residential homes with
their civilians inside each time you're
at a hospital in GZA ambulances are
bringing in children we filmed so many
children sleeping around in the beds of
the hospitals in the receptions and in
the corridors of the hospitals most
casualties as even doors tell it are of
the
children this is happening as the UN
Secretary General was earlier today on
the other side of the Border in Egypt
calling for Aid trucks to be allowed in
immediately any sign that anyone's
listening to him and that will happen
soon well the whole world now is talking
about the entering of Aid trucks that
have been declined the entering for over
almost two weeks now since they arrived
at the ra border the road to the ra
border crossing inside Gaza was
bombarded many times even to delay even
after the approval of the entering of
these trucks the delay of their entering
because they know that there is no
proper Road for these trucks to cross
into the G strip again we're talking
about 20
humanitarian Aid trucks for over two
million people in the worst conditions
ever Israel is saying that these trucks
are only for the southern parts of the
Gaza Strip that's H un and Raa and she's
saying it's also saying that they're
only going to be having uh carrying food
uh medication water so there's no sign
of uh Fuel and there is no sign of what
is needed for the rest of the strip
while there are thousands still here in
the northern part of Gaza and in Gaza
City we have seen thousands of them of
them in the shifa hospital and in other
hospitals in Gaza City uh what happens
to the rest of these people that is not
even uh part of the plan no one is
talking about that worse than that all
Sami is really that no no one is talking
about h a ceasefire or an instant
ceasefire for the ongoing air strikes
that are targeting civilians every now
and then in the G district and this is
the major problem now fuel is completely
running out of the strip hospitals have
called out for any person any private
facility that has any kind or amount of
fuel to bring to the hospitals in order
for them to keep operating and this is
what we have seen people and private
facilities do the past few days but
again people can't move around the strip
because of the shortage of fuel and
diesel in the strip so uh the crisis are
furthering getting complicated they're
compounding more and more and we're
still only hearing news about the
opening of the ra border for the
entering of humanitarian Aid trucks in
the Gaza stre all right you say there
from Gaza